this is hard I always have to soften
hitting like this after it's low no more is
makes more we crash for 40 strokes ago
always more we all crashed I had the night
I told everything everything they do not sing and
chaka chaka bed
from 14 years
and I'm learning to 217 18 years and
until teacher had already taught my dad
and you're going to work for me, you're my
son are you going to continue working he said is
he has time in each month grandfather is
willing to keep working and do not go
of 35
twigs of 35 cuerditas like these
then the three of them walk of three or
five days practically but what
we cut them together is today spend a
part then all electrifying is what
I am doing machucando and then
then it becomes 40 degrees
we do it like this we take it to the bridge
stylize then the second day shreds
pull to pull jalas then finish it
act de ya is ready to start a
theses days for the Lord leave it like this
doing it wrong they bounce doing it wrong or
boots that's a historic moment of
historical the monument for that every year
of we do not go to the monkey unless we have to
keep everything nice we have wanted
adore it so beautiful most of all to
take good care